bonsoir jacques de merci d'être avec
nous alors en substance à l'opposition
estime que le mandat de romenay le moïse
est arrivé à son terme mais le scrutin
de 2015 ayant été annulée le président
estime lui qu en ayant prêté serment en
2017 il lui reste un an au pouvoir qui a
raison qui a tort
vaste question
oui tout le débat tout le débat est là
tout le débat est là qu est il était dit
au moment de son élection de sa
réélection de dire je sais pas s'il faut
parler de réduction de ses dix ans au
moment de l'élection de 2017 cats il
était convenu qu at il été dit si on
s'en tient à la constitution la réponse
semble être du côté de jovial moïse
mais la contestation est la plus un
front de problèmes socio-économiques que
problème juridique d'un fond juridique
je vous l moïse s'appuie sur la question
que sur le point constitutionnel pour
dire que son mandat n'a commencé qu'en
évidemment la population considère qu'il
ya eu une une année depuis une année et
le flottement pendant laquelle il était
président donc son mandat devrait
s'achever
pour ai dû s'achever avant-hier mais
voilà la population n'en peut plus la
population est exemple il n'ya plus rien
en haïti vous êtes à port au prince n'a
pas l'électricité
les écoles ne fonctionne pas les
hôpitaux manquent de tout la fameuse la
reconstruction qui devraient avoir lieu
depuis le tremblement de terre depuis
deux 2010 a avancé très très timidement
pour ainsi dire rien n'a été fait alors
voilà quand vous avez ce fonds là
évidemment le prétexte est tout trouvé
pour dire ben monsieur moïse doit partir
donc voilà la question demeure est-ce
que qu'est-ce qui a été qu'est ce qui
lui a été dit quelle est la position
alors il ya une position qui reconnaît
aujourd'hui que la position de la cour
de cassation qui dit il doit partir
voilà vous faire il n'y a pas de réponse
faire bien sûr non mais c'est très
intéressant mais yahia
évidemment la réponse juridique qui sera
certainement la seule réponse valable
mais vous dites vous avez décrire l'état
de précarité de pauvreté d'haïti
à qui la faute justement gouvernement en
place qui n'a pas fait ce qu'il fallait
comment l'expliquer alors embaucher je
dois préciser qu'il ya en plus pour
avant de répondre à votre question il ya
encore un autre fonds l'autre fond c'est
la suspicion de corruption
si au journel moïse la corruption de
mots de quoi s'agit-il
il s'agit de la femme du fameux procès
petrohawk arriver c'est à dire c'était
ce sont des fonds qui on peut attribuer
pas directement par le venezuela le
venezuela avait permis qu haïti
s'approvisionnent en pétrole à coup à
prix coûtant et donc la marge dégagée
devait servir à de l'équipement à des
équipements sociaux enfin à améliorer
faut simplifier le sort de la population
rien dans ce sens n'a été fait et
monsieur josé luiz est soupçonné d'avoir
aidé à voir comme dirait comme dirait
l'ami les légendes et les milieux
douteux on à en avoir croqué par dans
couleurs sous le terme familier il aurai
en t s'est lui-même de son côté sept
cent mille dollars mac bourse à ceux ci
tout ça est au conditionnel mais il a
quand même il a quand même été inculpé
pour corruption
donc quand on a un président qui a été
aidé un personnage qui est inculpé pour
corruption qui n'a pas fait son travail
d'amélioration de la situation et que
les gens n'en peuvent plus ne voit pas
la fin
que voulez-vous que voulez vous qu'ils
se passent bien le source
on arrive proche de la fin du mandat on
dit mais le mandat est terminé
c'est pour cela que seulement 20% des
haïtiens ont voté aux dernières
élections ce qui remet quand même en
cause la légimité de journée louise déjà
21% voter et je faisais le mot issu il
faut donner les chiffres parce que les
pourcentages sont sont un peu dangereux
à peu près 5 millions d'haïtiens
le corps électoral c'est 5 millions
ici 5 millions d'haïtiens 20% c'est un
peu plus d'un million quand vous êtes
élu avec 55 % des votants ça vous fait
cinq cent mille cinq cent mille voix
cinq cent mille voix ça veut dire
exactement 10 % de la population des
votants qu'est-ce que vous quel est
l'âge et de la légitimité mais comme il
ya eu élection et que les résultats
étaient proclamés
voilà il a été élu mais quand on a cette
fragilité d'élections et qu'on arrive à
ne pas à ne pas satisfaire les besoins
primaires de la population de
l'électorat voilà la violence la tension
secret et comme vous voyez c'est
toujours c'est la réponse est toujours
la répression la répression la
répression et pourtant l'onu
jacques lion emile a décidé de ne pas
prendre parti sur mon plutôt soutenir le
calendrier du président actuel
c'est une surprise comment on peux se
l'expliquer oui c'est franchement une
surprise parce que le département d'état
est approuvée la communauté imposition
de jouvenel with je ne dis pas que je la
comprends mais je me l'expliquer parce
que les républicains pas en place
monsieur trompé qui viennent partir n'a
jamais voulu s'occuper de cette partie
là en terme en termes de géopolitique de
cette partie du monde
tout au moins le mépris vis-à-vis
d'haïti il savait il remonte à loin donc
voilà donc les américains disent et les
élus en haïti font enfin une assise
quand même très importante il faut quand
même savoir que depuis l'occupation
d'haïti par les états unis entre 1915 et
depuis cette époque ça veut dire plus de
cent ans tout ce qui se passe dans la
vie politique en haïti
tous les élus de la vie politique en
haïti l'ont été avec la caution je parle
des présidents ont été longs et et avec
la caution ou le silence des états unis
j'étais celui solide et celui d'aristide
90 en moins d'un an
un coup d'état à l'instant la nsa son
maiden
qui déclare soutenir le président en
place jusqu'à la fin de son mandat je
vous parliez justement des états unis
des silences ça tombe à point nommé
votre réaction
et oui voilà j'ai envie de vous dire les
américains démocrates ou républicains
voient la ccc ce qui est triste et qui
fait de la peine c'est ce mépris depuis
cela remonte à l'histoire depuis 1804
haïti est indépendant haïti est un
problème est une épine dans le pied dans
le pied du de de la communauté les
dirigeants occidentaux internationaux
c'est un problème vous savez ça il faut
dire les choses que l'on doit dire les
choses comme il faut maintenant sans
hypocrisie sans haine froidement cette
histoire haïti devient indépendant c'est
une bonne d'esclaves
quand on les a appelés les glorieuses
vous en haïti nous disons des
va-nu-pieds une main de van impe pied
qui ont battu la remuée de l'armée de
napoléon en france pendant longtemps on
a choisi de ne pas en parler
si je vous dis la bataille de vertières
vous avez fait des études vous ne savez
pas ce que c'est enfin peut-être vous si
vous avez lu si vous êtes intéressé à
l'éthique la bataille de vienne ouverte
hier 18 novembre 1803 mais c'est la
première mêlera clé qu'a prises l'armée
de 20,2 du général bonaparte en haïti
bah ça on en a pas parlé pendant plus de
150 ans vous voyez les états unis quel
mauvais exemple à hitiaa constitué pour
les états unis qui était un pays
esclavagistes qui avait plusieurs
millions d'esclaves noirs sur son sol
vous vous rendez compte de l'exemple que
des noirs soient devenus indépendants et
fo et les fonds de l'état
voilà tout ça est ajouté à ça je dirais
cette haine je ponds d'air cette
détestation ou bien ce nom amour de
l'international plus le mauvais
comportement
la corruptibilité cissé française que
jeudi des dirigeants de certains
dirigeants ici qu'est ce que ça donne
parce qu'il ne faut pas accuser que d'un
côté et ne pas accuser l'autre il ya
deux coupables
belligérants coupable dans la sphère
aussi bien la classe politique haïtienne
traditionnels que la la société
internationale merci un exemple simple
allez je peux vous dire quand même
l'exemple du libre ça qu'on veut c'est
important regardez ce qui s'est passé au
liban
monsieur mâcon s'est déplacé il est dit
on va vous aider à condition que jusqu'à
présent ce n'est pas réglé mais la coupe
la condition est toujours en suspens
jameer la disent en haïti jamais on l'a
dit alors nous les haïtiens nous savons
tous nous avons une liasse pour
important très instruite d'un niveau
très élevé capable de diriger un pays
mais si tout le monde veut être
président il n'y a qu'un seul président
si tout le monde veut être président
mais ce n'est pas possible donc la
culpabilité des deux côtés on ne peut
pas accuser que le que la communauté
internationale et ne pas prendre part de
responsabilité ce qui se passe en haïti
c'est l'aboutissement d'un véritable
pourrissement depuis 200 ans
je suis désolé mon langage est dur mais
je pense aux peuples qui souffrent et
qui n'a rien et qui voit passer qui est
toujours témoin de sa toujours témoin
témoin sans aucune ressource qu'est ce
qui reste
la violence le suicide même merci les
haïtiens n'ont pas peur des armes ils
vont te tuer voilà merci beaucoup
jacques heurts les ont émis le président
de l'association haïti mémoire d'avoir
été avec nous avoir apporté votre
sentiment merci à vous haïti mémoires et
cultures si je peux me permettre haïti
mais pour cette de précision merci en
tout cas vosges à cléon et 1000